the world keeps changing people keep
evolving it's nice to meet you elliott
so by the time this goes up which will
be two days after
um it has been made public then you are
probably aware of
elliott page now i am going to use um
his previous name his dead name
just once for clarification in case
anyone is not up to
speed i'm gonna stop myself there
because
what i thought i needed to do was to say
elliot's dead name at least once to be
sure everyone knew who i was talking
about
however this situation that should not
be
necessary because much to my surprise
imdb wikipedia and google have
completely updated
all of his references so you can now say
hey elliott page came out as transit
people say who's that you can just say
hey let me show you on the imdb page and
they will realize immediately oh
same actor as juno same actor as
umbrella academy
no need to dead name not even for
clarification
wow the internet actually worked for
once anyway breathe a sigh of relief and
i'll hand it back
to me elliott is uh
trans non-binary and
i'm really excited that he's come out
but obviously if you're not overly
steeped in
lgbtq queerness like i am
obviously you might have questions you
might have points of confusion so i want
to help
and then i want to tie this in directly
with
umbrella academy and the possible future
of
that show so if you're here for that
stick around i'll get there
but first we have to talk about how we
talk about these things
when you're talking about a public
figure or even someone who you know
personally when you're conversing with
someone
who does not know them post-transition
and only knows them
pre-transition that is a situation where
you will probably have to use their dead
name at least once
to be sure that the person you're
speaking with knows who you're talking
about
[Music]
after that though you should
not be using their dead name that's why
it's called
a dead name because it's dead and buried
that is not their identity any longer
if you use it by accident that's fine
correct it and definitely don't get
angry with anyone who catches it and
corrects
you which brings us to pronouns
i am going to be using he and they even
if
i make any reference to roles that
elliot has played previously such as say
juno
which was the role that he got an oscar
nomination for
now even though
at the time elliot was presenting
as a woman i almost said identifying as
a woman
i don't know what his timeline was i
don't know how he identified at the time
but regardless that's not who he is now
and
this is kind of a bit of trans
conversational etiquette when you refer
to a trans person
even if you are referring back to
events or things they did prior to their
transition
you still use their current preferred
name and pronouns now i understand that
can throw you off and be a bit
weird and confusing and it can take a
little work to get into your headspace
but here's a way to think about it
how do you talk about the actor tyler
perry
and the character medea
pretty sure if you've ever referred to
either one
he's the actor she's the character
it's the same with elliot all of the
female roles that elliot played
are still female roles those roles those
characters don't suddenly become
trans retroactively you don't have to
start using male
pronouns to refer to the character of
juno
even though you need to now be using
male or they
them pronouns to be referring to elliott
the actor even if you're referring to
the acting work he did
way back in something like juno but
that's the comparison to keep in mind
he they actor she character
it's actually not as confusing as people
tend to make it out
what can be confusing is when we have to
overwrite the defaults and the things
that we've been using for a while
that can be tricky but the general
concept is not hard you're probably
already doing it with other people so
with all that having been said
and now that we've covered how
to discuss elliott let's talk about
elliot's acting prospects and
specifically i do want to focus on
umbrella academy because that puts
us in a fairly unique position because
broadly speaking in terms of things like
film roles
elliott will make his choices
with his current now out publicly known
identity in mind
but umbrella academy is an ongoing show
and the character that he plays vania
hargreaves is already established as
female now first i want to tackle
a number of the things that i've already
seen come up sometimes being asked
sincerely well what about this and
sometimes being stated
in bad faith as reasons why
this somehow isn't okay and we need to
recast or whatever else
anyone who is giving you a reason
why elliot can no longer play vanya
is either a transphobe arguing in bad
faith
or someone who is parroting the
arguments of transphobes originally made
in bad faith and whether they know that
or not that still it ties back to
yeah i'm not going to mince words about
that i will still address all of the
concerns
and i'll do so as if they were good
faith but
most of them aren't so
let's talk about a few things first off
every indication is that elliot will
remain
in the show in fact shortly after
elliott came out and
made his uh identity and truth known to
the world
netflix tweeted out that they couldn't
wait to work with him in season three
of umbrella academy now we should also
clarify where umbrella academy
is at this point their renewal for
season three was
only confirmed last month so uh their
shooting is scheduled to begin in
february i could not
find a reliable source on how far along
the scripting
is now presumably they would have been
working to some degree on scripts maybe
hadn't locked it all down yet waiting
for the
renewal but there is time
between now and when shooting starts
there's several months now that's not
enough to
if if the decision was made and we'll
deal with the possibilities in a minute
but if the decision was made
to integrate a trans narrative into
vania's story in umbrella academy
it there may not be the time to work in
a completely from the ground
up edition or anything that would
require
new locations new actors not already
cast and things like that because even
though shooting doesn't start to
february between now and then
is when the logistics are worked out
schedules are locked down
locations are secured etc etc however
that would not preclude them from
altering scenes and
rewriting certain things to allow for
that narrative to be worked into
whatever else is already going on
so long as it doesn't require new
locations new characters etc
because that kind of stuff also ups your
budget
so there is time for them to do any
number of things
but the questions that come up are
can elliot
a trans non-binary person
play what has up to this point been a
cisgender
woman and the answer to that is of
course he freaking can
now i'm not even going to entertain
the whole oh what you're saying a trans
person can play a cis
part but you've said before that cis
actors can't play trans people yes i
have and
refresh yourself on the video
where i talked about that because i'm
not i'm not entertaining that argument
here
yes he can play a cis woman
no cis people can't play trans
characters
not right now no so let's tackle
some of the things that i see being
brought up mostly
this first one especially is almost
always in bad faith the idea often gets
floated that
he couldn't play vinya because it would
give him dysphoria to play a woman
first of all i hate seeing that come up
it's one of the things i've been meaning
to tackle for a while
dysphoria is incredibly
personal and specific to every
individual who experiences it
a b not every trans person has dysphoria
or at least not severe dysphoria it's
part of the
narrative in pop culture that people
transition because
their dysphoria is so bad that's what
they have to do that is
not the truth for all trans people
and let us not forget
elliot is an actor it is not
unreasonable to assume
he's capable of taking on a part without
it triggering dysphoria
is it possible for
elliot or any trans actor to experience
debilitating dysphoria by having to
portray
a gender that they once were forced to
present
as and may have trauma related to that
yes
that is possible but you cannot take it
as a given
unless elliot says i can't play a cis
woman because of my dysphoria then this
option isn't on the table
you don't get to decide in advance that
he can't play this part because of that
only he can say whether or not dysphoria
is an issue for him
so drop that one so unless he says
otherwise elliot is
absolutely fully capable of slipping
back in to the character of vinya and
playing vinya
as a cis woman
it's also an option to introduce trans
elements into the character
anyone who brings up the idea that well
they can't do that because that's not
being true to the character
uh hold up do you have any idea how many
changes have already been made to these
characters in this adaptation
sticking on vinya specifically buying
his sexuality so far as i could find is
never
addressed in the comics and yet she is
now established as
being bisexual in the show
so we've already deviated right there
in the comic all of these characters are
white
like really white we have a very
mixed ethnicity group in the show
they're not obligated to stay true to
every single detail
of these characters they're allowed to
do their own thing they already have
done with vanya with her entire
story and character arc in the second
season
was based around material not in the
comics
so if your concern is it's not being
true to the character you shouldn't even
be watching the show anymore you would
have had to have written it off
heck season one definitely season two
so don't come at me with that one
umbrella academy has a
unique opportunity to integrate
a trans actor's story and life
experience
into a character not originally designed
for that story
but you can still bring those things in
i've talked about this thing
sort of thing before when i talked about
characters who were
turned gay later in their life but were
not originally written to be that at
their initial conception there's the
thing so there is a validity to doing
that because a lot of people
either come to a realization about
themselves later in life
or even if they don't they don't come
out until later in life as
elliot himself is evidence of
that having been said just because they
have the opportunity doesn't mean that
they have to take it
maybe elliott doesn't want his
transition to be highlighted in the work
that he does
maybe they can't figure out a way to
integrate it cleanly
there's any number of reasons for them
to not do it
so i also want to be clear that while i
think it's an opportunity and i
would kind of like to see it addressed
in some
fashion the show isn't obligated to and
i would not be
mad at it if it doesn't
because it's still the same character
it's still the same actor who is very
good in the part
how that actor is identifying away from
the part
having changed doesn't affect
any of that so those were all the major
points that i wanted to hit in talking
about
elliott having come out and it's ripple
effects on
umbrella academy so
thank you for listening be polite use
correct pronouns
don't dead name
and we'll all move forward so thank you
very much
for watching usual stuff like share
subscribe
got a patreon it's how i pay my bills
and it is greatly appreciated keeps the
lights on around here
but you also don't have to do any of it
because end of the day
you are the council i just run the
meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]